[Music]
wreckit-ralph - is finally in cinemas
and it's even more amazing than we
thought it will be but do you know the
voices behind every single character
stay tuned to find out which two
extremely famous youtubers got a part in
wreck-it Ralph - do you love Disney make
sure to hit that like and subscribe
button for even more fun now let's check
out the behind the scenes of wreck-it
Ralph - character voices I renewed our
as Pocahontas let's start with a voice
actress that has so much energy just
looking at her makes you smile
Irene Bedard is the original speaking
voice of Pocahontas so it's only fair
she portrayed Pocahontas in wreck-it
Ralph - what kind of a princess are you
I am the voice of Pocahontas in the film
and I'm also your guide for this
behind-the-scenes adventure Irene is
actually a Native American in real life
so she definitely does justice to
Pocahontas is character and although
she's a bundle of energy her voice is so
incredibly soothing it makes us close
our eyes and pretend we're back in the
original movie Kristen Bell as Anna
Kristen Bella is one of those hashtag
relatable actresses you just can't help
but love she's absolutely hilarious it's
a holiday when we celebrate a movie
about a brother and a sister who kiss of
course she's the voice of Anna in frozen
but did you know that she's also the
voice of Gossip Girl her character gets
revealed right at the end and no one
even suspects a theme you're not going
to along with returning to voice Anna in
wreck-it Ralph - Christian has had major
success as we'll be seeing her again in
frozen - you can also catch her in a
hilarious show it's a good place and one
of our favorites Veronica Mars is
finally returning on Hulu for its fourth
season
she's definitely a busy one isn't she
Jodi Benson as Ariel
although Alyssa Milano was the one that
gave Ariel her look Jodi Benson gave her
her voice check her out here recording
part of your world this video belongs to
RDO dally & Co who did an awesome job
capturing Jodi getting familiar with
this
we all know and love
[Music]
isn't she adorable we can't imagine
anyone else giving Arielle or her boys
so it only makes sense that she returned
for the wreckit-ralph to Disney Princess
reunion Jodi's voice is still
recognizable isn't it
zoom you made a deal with an underwater
sea witch where she took your voice in
exchange for a pair of human legs
seriously Jody is the most perfect Ariel
out Leah follow as Moana speaking of
perfect Disney princesses we still can't
believe that Ali he practically looks
like Moana and it was all a coincidence
it's like Moana in real life I could be
the perfect daughter but I coming back
to the water one of the reasons why Elly
is the perfect Moana is also because
Disney definitely did its research to
make sure Pacific Islanders are
represented correctly
[Music]
although Moana didn't really say much in
wreckit-ralph - we're still so happy she
was there she's not considered a Disney
princess by the official standards but
she's definitely a Disney princess in
our own lineup Jennifer Hale as
Cinderella okay here's the thing
Jennifer Hale isn't the original voice
of Cinderella the original belongs
styling in woods who unfortunately
passed away in 2010 since then Jennifer
took her place as Cinderella in various
games and other appearances here's what
she looks like it was wonderful
but Cinderella is not the only character
Jennifer voices in fact you can find her
voice in some of your faith video games
she even crossed over to another world
and gave voice to Alana in the Little
Mermaid Ariel's beginning a true
multi-talented voice actress isn't she
Kate Higgins as Aurora meets Kate
Higgins the voice behind one of the most
forgotten Disney Princesses ever
although Kate is not the original voice
of Aurora she gave the character a voice
in Sofia the first although the original
Aurora voice actress is still alive she
wasn't brought back for the
wreckit-ralph to role Kate said it
herself that Aurora might not have a lot
of lines but then she added this which
is most definitely true I mean she's a
classic you know and they they treated
it like that although Aurora doesn't
speak much it would be nice to see this
classic role rebooted in the future
don't you think put a modern twist to it
Disney Linda Larkin as jasmine Disney
fans have always pointed out that Linda
Larkin the original voice of jasmine is
incredibly kind in real life just like
an actual Disney Princess you can really
hear the actual Jasmine in this clip I
want to thank you for stopping that man
not many people would have done that
jasmine delivers one of the best lines
when she asks vanellope if she has daddy
issues see it for yourself do you have
daddy issues
you know Mom we love the meta humor
that's going on in the Disney Princess
parts of the movie and yep we'll be
getting a live remake of Aladdin in 2019
but unfortunately Linda won't be
returning as Jasmine so make sure you
get enough of her adorable voice in
wreck-it Ralph - Kelly Macdonald has
Merida Kelly Macdonald is an original
Merida and she made a return in the
get Ralph to movie we all collectively
lost it when we saw the extended clip of
vanellope
and other princesses looking slightly
confused with her accent and pure mace I
don't know Wes here's what Elly looks
like in real life
her hair is definitely not as big or
curly as Merida's but she definitely has
the accent firstborn descendant of Clan
dunbroch Merida is one of those
characters that's just so unique to
Disney's portfolio we just can't help
but feel proud of her accomplishments
and by the looks of it Kelly is just as
fond of her character as we are idina
menzel as Elsa and here comes the let it
go Queen I also really changed the game
when it came to Disney Princesses and
she's not even on the official princess
list but idina menzel is without a doubt
a princess in her own right we bet a lot
of people can actually relate to else's
character but Idina is just so sweet she
didn't even take it to heart when John
Travolta made this unfortunate mistake
of pronouncing her name wrong please
welcome the wickedly talented one and
only a true Queen isn't she
still waiting for Disney to officially
crown her and Anna as princesses Mandy
Moore as Rapunzel the name Mandy Moore
probably doesn't ring a bell if you were
born anywhere after 2005 but nineties
babies might remember Mandy Moore from
Princess Diaries no seriously she was in
Princess Diaries
and she's also Rapunzel in the original
tangled movie as well as in wreck-it
Ralph - here she is spilling some meta
truth about Disney Princesses do you
notice that right before this moment
Rapunzel was the only one that didn't
join in when princesses announced that
they don't have a mom and now for the
million dollar question she's among the
handful that actually does we absolutely
adore Mandy's voice and we hope this
isn't the last time she'll be reprising
her role as Rapunzel pamela ribbon as
Snow White the original melodic voice of
Snow White belongs to adriana caselotti
but after Adriana's passing pamela
ribbon insured to carry on the legacy
honestly we can't believe they got away
with it either Pamela did a great job
bringing snow-white back to life and
giving her that sweet melodic voice
again even though Snow White has been
criticized for her stereotypical role
it's nice to see her hang out with some
of the more modern Disney Princesses
anika Noni Rose as Tiana speaking of
classic princesses Tiana is perhaps the
most underrated ones out of all she's
definitely a princess that isn't exactly
fit to the standard stereotypes and her
voice actress anika Noni Rose absolutely
loves the role in case you don't know
Anika was actually Laura L in dream
girls that's right a dizzy princessing
next up Beyonce
seriously Anika has an amazing voice
just look at her casually belting high
notes
even though Tiana didn't say much in
wreckit-ralph to movie it was amazing
seeing Anika reprise her role as one of
our faith Disney Princesses Minah when
as Mulan here's another voice actress
that's been pretty busy since portraying
Mulan in the original movie her name is
Mina when and she's absolutely adorable
with all due respect your excellency I
think I've been away from home long
enough if she looks familiar you
probably know her from playing Melinda
May in Marvel's agents of shield how
about I do you a favor and not tell
anyone not a tiny little Asian woman
kicked her yep Melinda Mae is secretly a
Disney Princess of course Ming Na when
does a fantastic job as Mulan and it's
so nice to see her back in Disney action
speaking of action unfortunately me know
when won't be returning to portray Mulan
in the live-action movie coming in 2020
so make sure you watch wreck-it Ralph
too for your dose of OG Mulan john c
reilly as ralph and now let's move on to
other actors that made wreck-it ralph to
what it is and one of those actors is
without a doubt john c reilly who plays
the one and only ralph youtube-channel
the a/v Club shared a funny video of
John explaining what it's like to be a
voice actor for Ralph oh honey look who
it is it's wreck-it Ralph and the kids
like no it's not it looks nothing like
wreck-it Ralph he went on to explain
that kids seem to think Ralph is an
actual real character that would be
absolutely hilarious if that were true
we're still giggling about this moment
from the movie Sarah Silverman and who
could possibly forget about the new
addition to the Disney Princess family
the one and only vanellope
she's voiced by Sarah Silverman who of
course also voiced vanilla pee in the
first movie
seriously her original voice is sort of
similar to vanilla peas and it's equally
as adorable you can kind of hear her
cartoon voice coming out right
Sarah is extremely proud of her role as
Penelope who by the way is actually the
first Jewish Disney Princess that's a
huge thing for Disney as well as it's
conspiracy theorists but that's a topic
for another video let's move on to some
other voice actors gal gadot as Shane
everyone collectively screamed when gal
gadot was added to the wreckit-ralph to
cast list we loved her in Wonder Woman
and we loved her even more as shank and
wreck-it Ralph - there's no law saying
best friends have to have the same
dreams
Ralph refers to her as that shank lady
which is absolutely hilarious in real
life gal gadot is far from a
tough-as-nails type of character good
yeah for little children seriously she's
pretty goofy this was actually gal gadot
first time doing voiceover work and we
have a feeling this is only the
beginning
taraji P Henson as yes yes which by the
way is spelled as yes with two extra
less letters is one of the most perfect
characters she's the algorithm the same
algorithm that tells us when something
comes on her feet on YouTube Facebook
and Instagram
[Music]
she's voiced by taraji P Henson who has
an extensive acting resume if her voice
sounds familiar
you probably remember her as the mom
from Jaden Smith's Karate Kid you heard
I'm he ran into a pole taraji said that
getting that wreckit-ralph call was like
a dream come true and some things she
got to cross off her bucket lists that
must have been a pretty awesome feeling
Jack McBrayer as Felix everyone had one
question when we first heard about the
second movie is Felix going to be in it
well of course he is Felix is played by
Jack McBrayer who also played herbing in
Phineas and Ferb you allow me to
introduce myself
I'm curving wreckit-ralph wouldn't be
complete without him Jack said that
Felix in him
look quite alike and they even captured
some of the same features in his
animated character he said that the
entire experience of filming the second
movie was just way too fun and we can
imagine why it looks awesome to work
behind the scenes on wreck-it Ralph to
Jane Lynch as Calhoun one of the most
distinctive voices in wreck-it Ralph is
without a doubt Jane Lynch Calhoun is a
fan favorite character and we're so
happy to see Jane Lynch back in the
second movie Kohut my cruiser
[Applause]
of course the romance between her and
Felix is our absolute favorite Side
Story in wreck-it Ralph as you already
know Jane Lynch is just as hilarious
behind the scenes as she is in the movie
who can forget her role as Sue Sylvester
in Glee look at me even in the heat of
battle I'm so elegant we love her just
as much as we love her last two voice
actresses glozell green as Little Debbie
glozell might have a minor part in the
movie but since she's a fellow youtuber
we just have to give her credit if you
have never seen her content you
absolutely have to check her out because
she's hilarious bck online YouTube
channel caught up with her at the red
carpet premiere of the second movie
seriously she's so funny
the fans were really excited to catch a
glimpse of an even bigger YouTube star
Colleen ballinger as herself dude a
recent changes Colleen ballinger went
through in her YouTube career it's
absolutely heartwarming to see Colleen
aka Miranda sings being a part of this
movie the movie also pays homage to
several other digital influencers but
fans were literally screaming when they
saw a short clip of Colleen what and
although she's credited as Colleen and
not Miranda sings you can sort of hear
her Miranda character it's even more
heartwarming because earlier this year
Colleen announced that she's saying
goodbye to Miranda at least for a while
what a lovely tribute
did you like wreckit-ralph - what did
you think of the disney princess scene
we absolutely loved it but we want to
hear from you
come let us know your thoughts in the
comment section below
that's it for our video don't forget to
hit that like button subscribe to the
things and we'll see you next time
[Music]